today on a special edition of Brian Ross
investigates unmasking the truth
President Trump makes a point of not
wearing a mask at the White House and
calls out those who do reporters and his
Democratic rival who can you take it up
because I cannot hear I'll just speak
louder sir okay good you want to be
politically correct he's a fool absolute
fool we'll talk with the professor who
studied how masks were used to such good
effect in the last great pandemic in
1918 and his fears of what may be in
store for us now I fear there will be a
second spike of cases and there may not
be the will to implement these you know
rather strict closure orders Plus this
week's winners I never saw a White House
press secretary
act like that and losers in the media
this is why he won't wear a man doesn't
want to look funny see if you agree with
the editor-in-chief of media and your
questions about both of 19 and the law
your job your home you're right
we really need the funds please tell me
where to turn from the law and crime
Network this is a special covered 19
edition of Brian Ross investigates thank
you for joining us and welcome to our
viewers on YouTube live and Facebook
life
I'm Brian Ross joined today by my
colleague at the law and crime Network
Rhonda Schwartz and Rhonda this week
marked a sad and grim milestone for this
country 100,000 Americans dead when the
covered 19 pandemic certainly no cause
for celebration but also not something
that should be ignored
it's a horrible milestone in hard to
even say it out loud president Trump
marked the marked this horrific event on
Twitter today one of many tweets he sent
us how he sent his condolences to the
nation but even so he still refuses to
wear a mask in public which public
health officials have basically told
everyone to do to prevent more deaths
that's right he seems to be undercutting
the advice from his own medical team in
fact he's been making fun and poke
people who do wear masks as if somehow
it's not manly yes what happened the
other day at the White House no Biden
can wear a mask but he was standing
outside with his wife perfect conditions
perfect weather they were inside they
don't wear masks and so I thought it was
very unusual that he had one on but I
thought that was fine I wasn't
criticizing him at all why would I ever
do a thing like that and your second
question was I couldn't hear you this
second can you take it up because I
cannot hear I'll just speak louder sir
okay good you want to be politically
correct go ahead no sir I just want to
wear that is good and then Vice
President Biden fired right back at the
president he's a fool an absolute fool
to talk that way I mean every leading
doc in the world is saying we should
wear a mask when you're in a crowd
presidents are supposed to lead not
engage in folly and be falsely masculine
of course in the history of pandemics
masks have proven to be very effective
and to know more about that I talked
earlier this week with J Alexander
Navarro who is a professor at the
University of Michigan in the history
and medicine department and he has done
a special report for the CDC and the
Department of Defense of what happened
more than a hundred years ago in the
1918 influenza pandemic dr. Navarro
thank you so much for joining us if we
told our viewers that New York did
pretty well in the pandemic a lot better
than many other cities they wouldn't
know what we're talking about but there
would be some truth right about 1918
there be some truth New York did did
fairly well considering that it did not
implement a wide range of these
non-pharmaceutical interventions they
pretty much relied on a very stringent
isolation and quarantine regimen where
they tried to identify cases of
influenza as quickly as possible and
remove them from from circulation and we
see the pictures you've gathered from
1918 it's a part of history that I never
was taught in school the influenza
epidemic and the use of widespread use
of mass you
so masks were were recommended in a lot
of places a lot of people across the
country did use them and they were
mandated in certain cities Denver for
example San Francisco was a big example
Oakland Seattle these are communities
that mandated the use of face masks and
in most of those cities when it was
mandated there was quite a lot of
pushback and in San Francisco in fact
there was so much pushback at a group of
protesters form what they called the
anti mask League and there were at least
2,000 members we don't have a roster of
who was involved in this but we know
that in 1919 as the the third wave of
the epidemic rolled on at least 2,000
people gathered for a meeting to hear
you know sort of protests about why
these masks the mandatory masks
ordinance was unconstitutional and why
masks from a public health standpoint
didn't work and they were definitely
much hated by a large portion of the of
the San Francisco population so we see
playing out again now in 2020 with
President Trump notably not wearing a
mask and his potential Democratic rival
former Vice President Biden making a
point of wearing a mask and criticizing
President Trump for criticizing him but
wearing a mask what do you make of what
lessons should have been learned what
lessons were going to learn today well
you know the mask thing is interesting
if you take San Francisco for example
the first time it seemed Cisco rolled
out this mask ordinance was in the fall
along with some closures of places of
public amusement and there was a
definite push both at the state level
which recommended the use of masks and
definitely at the local level by groups
like the Red Cross for example and
physicians who wanted this there was a
push to tie wearing of masks to
patriotism and of course this is a time
of world war one so the idea was that
you can enjoin people to do what they
can on the homefront they can't
necessarily fight in the war but if our
boys are overseas fighting in the war
the least you can do here is to protect
society here by wearing a mask and there
were phrase like don't be a mask slacker
for example because there were people
who refused to wear them in public or
people who had the mob but maybe pulled
them down to smoke a cigar
or get a breath of fresh air you know so
there was definitely that that political
component to it you know the fear today
of course is that we know that masks are
fairly effective there they're
definitely more effective today than
they were back in 1918 and their recent
studies that I just read one recently
that based on some modeling that says if
we can get 80% compliance of mask
wearing while people are in public we
might be able to reduce Kovach cases by
is by maybe just 1/12 of the amount that
we have now so that's a pretty drastic
reduction of course getting compliance
is difficult you know I 80 percent
doesn't seem too high but I do see lots
of evidence of people circulating out in
public thinking that maybe because
they're outdoors they're safe so going
to boardwalks and beaches for example
and not wearing masks and so I think
there are lots of lessons to draw from
1918 in terms of of how society
responded and what lesson can we draw
from more than a hundred years ago about
the expected second or third wave of
this pandemic so it's a little bit
difficult
of course because influenza and Cova are
caused by two different viruses so we
can't say for sure that there will be
another wave it seems likely and the
epidemiologist and public health experts
seem to be unanimous in their feeling
that they're most likely will be a wave
and another wave in the fall what I can
say from the historical perspective is
that when looking at 1918 when these
closure orders were removed and this was
generally in around Armistice Day in a
lot of cities sometimes a little bit
earlier in the East Coast and maybe a
little bit later in the West Coast they
a lot of cities about half of the cities
we studied saw a second spike of cases
as people started to circulate in mingle
again and in just two examples San
Antonio and Grand Rapids Michigan were
the only two cities that we studied
where those communities were able to
re-implement the same level of closure
orders a second time in every other
community that faced another spike of
cases there wasn't the political will or
the economic will to implement another
round of closure orders and these
closure orders in 1918 we're not as
sweeping as they are today and so I
think the lesson is and
my fear is that once you remove these
closure orders and these
non-pharmaceutical interventions and
people are clamoring to get back to life
as normal whatever the epidemic is going
to do it's going to continue to do you
still have a population of people who
are susceptible to it and it's going to
prove I think today as it did in 1918
incredibly difficult to sort of put that
toothpaste back in the tube if you will
to implement another round of closure
orders if it becomes necessary and if
people don't follow this social
distancing guidelines the the
recommendation to wear a mask for
example they gather in large groups
regardless if it's indoors or outdoors I
fear there will be a second spike of
cases and there may not be the will to
implement these you know rather strict
closure orders I understand that people
don't like them but they're designed to
sort of get us back to a place where we
can more carefully manage the epidemic
and if we don't stay at that level where
we can carefully manage it I think we're
in for a rough ride
well dr. Navarro has some important
lessons to be learned as always from the
past we can learn from history thank you
so much for all your research and thanks
for being with us here today thank you
and you're welcome coming up the race
for a covered 19 vaccine and your
questions about covered 19 and the law
should people who ignore the social
distancing rules be treated like
criminals you're watching the law on
crime trial Network
continuing now with your questions about
covert 19 in the law I'm joined by Bruce
park head of the firm Barket Epstein and
by utilizing ring of the same firm and
first let me start with you there is
some concern lots of questions about
whether people who ignore these social
distancing rules and mask rules should
they be treated like criminals good
afternoon thanks for having us
absolutely not the idea that somebody
would be incarcerated or punished as a
criminal for not following guidelines
issued by a governor troubles and should
trouble us all these are guidelines are
being issued daily they change daily
forgive me for calling this science but
the science behind some of these orders
changes dailies also you may recall that
initially we were told don't wear masks
they'll do no good you can get koban 19
from surfaces now we're being told the
exact opposite by the same people who
are telling us what we should have done
in the first instance these are
guidelines
people should follow them if they
believe them to be correct but they're
not criminal laws that weren't passed by
the legislature and even if they were I
think that be struck down by the courts
well I you too let me ask you this there
have been people who have been placed
under arrest sign of fines issued what's
going to happen when those cases end up
in court Aida well I imagine all the
good defense attorneys of each state are
gonna fight them vigorously as Bruce
mentioned these are not actual laws that
have been legislated and enacted
furthermore there's some confusion as to
what the laws actually are now a lot of
people don't know this but in New York
one of the penal law violations is
you're not permitted to wear a mask
unless it has exceptions it's a
masquerade party so at some point you
were told or actually it's current law
now that you shouldn't wear a mask
now this pandemic happens the governor
tells you that you have to wear one if
you can't socially distance within six
feet and the order is technically
inconsistent with the law that's
actually on the books right and as Bruce
said early on we ever told mass didn't
do that much good don't worry about it
now we're told the exact opposite Bruce
a question for you from Rhonda Schwarz
Rhonda Bruce you're known for your
white-collar criminal defense work and
what is happening with your clients with
the courts closed what are the risks and
issues facing the folks who have cases
pending in the criminal justice system
well it really is a Tale of Two Cities
individuals who are out on bail and who
are otherwise functioning are perfectly
happy to have the courts stay closed
forever because at the end of the day
for them is a trial and excuse me in the
risk of a conviction for those who are
clients who are in jail who are
incarcerated this is torture
they are literally locked in their cells
23 hours a day no visits at all no legal
visits no social visits no family
members very little time to speak to
their family and they're simply
languishing there so for clients facing
criminal charges it really depends on
whether or not you were fortunate enough
rich enough to of hosted bail absolutely
we've seen again and again in prisons
nursing homes and Indian reservations
terrible death tolls from the pandemic
now let me ask you this for people who
are locked up and get this disease and
don't do well is there a legal recourse
for them against the wardens against the
prison systems you would have to look at
the individual facts and also whether
there was any litigation and warning
about pre-existing conditions a lot of
inmates do have hypertension do have
heart disease and are at risk of a fatal
kovat infection now each prison and each
pretrial detention facility works
differently and has their own set of
rules
I've spoken to clients that
for weeks were not given masks we're not
given gloves were permitted to go into a
common room with 12 other individuals
they said the cleaning was no more than
it had been in the past in other
facilities there is no way to thoroughly
isolate each inmate from one another and
they're actually in dormitories there
have been instances where many inmates
have actually gotten Co vyd and we're
not tested or the public wasn't told
about it so I do foresee many lawsuits
coming forward and Bruce I've been
talking with a number of people who are
still behind bars they were initially
promised their sentences would be
reduced they'd be able to go home
because of the Cova 19 and now the rules
have changed what are you finding in
terms of trying to get people out of
prison because of the health risk well
initially it was actually somewhat
easier as the restrictions are being
reduced across the board the sense that
prisoners are the greater risk is also
being reduced so judges are less and
less likely to grant release to people
now than they were initially when the
fear factor if you will is significantly
higher and that's troubling because the
Koba threat in prison it is just as
severes now as it was a month ago it
hasn't changed and in some ways it's
worsened because you have this closed in
locked environment with virus traveling
around in there so it's been difficult
for individuals that are still
incarcerated and I let me ask you in
addition to people being arrested for
not following social distancing
guidelines there have been other
criminal cases that have come because of
the quarantine one fraud with some of
the applications for the federal grant
money and also issues of domestic abuse
what do you see about that and how is
that being handled well the issues with
domestic violence have to be taken
seriously on all directions and here's
situation you have a couple there's an
increase in drinking across many homes
people just get on each other's nerves
so there may be a dispute that does not
rise to the level that necessitates
incarceration or an order of protection
but in almost every case where there's a
domestic incident most judges are going
to issue orders of protection that means
that now either the husband or the wife
can't go home it also means that they're
then forced to go into another home
thereby potentially infecting say their
elderly parents and so forth so it is
troubling and it's very serious at the
same time we're seeing a huge decrease
in DWIs and in residential burglaries so
there's upsides and downsides to how be
pandemic is is affecting criminal cases
and Bruce we've heard from a number of
small business owners who are concerned
they may be walking themselves into
legal troubles because of the way they
got money from the government for grants
and whether they used it properly or not
what's your best advice might they
really face criminal prosecution well no
the criminal prosecution wouldn't be a
consequence of using the money
improperly as long as you were truthful
in filling out the application so
there's two parts to the process the
first part is you're applying for the
money and you made representations about
costs of employees rent and interest on
aligning ticket looks like we they have
spruce there I you know I'm going to ask
you to pick it up there while we get
Bruce's connection re-established that
issue Aida if you can hear me what
happens to people that have applied for
some of the federal grant money and the
figures weren't quite right
well it goes to every criminal every
crime has to have an element of a mens
rea out most every crime what that means
is that the individual actually intended
to defraud now there's a lot of
confusion out there as to who's eligible
and who isn't eligible if it's a matter
of bad advice or just an accident and
genuine the person didn't know or the
business didn't know and that's not
going to be criminalized but if there's
sufficient evidence of an intent to
defraud that would be something that's
eligible to for an arrest and these are
difficult times and going back for a
moment with their question about
domestic violence isn't usually a
procedure for police they almost are
mandated to make an arrest if they
respond to a domestic violence report
yes
whenever anybody files a complaint and
the police show up at your door even if
that individual says I wasn't serious I
was just angry nothing actually happened
nobody's really hurt if the allegation
was one of violence then in almost every
case the police guidelines are mandatory
arrest and then figure it out later they
do actually have discretion and I think
during the pandemic the police ought to
exercise their discretion especially
given the fact that tensions are on the
rise and people are required to stay
home and many people don't have other
places to go without reinfecting other
individuals God said you do have to take
true instances of domestic violence
seriously and protect the victims you
know we're now seeing around the country
some states some courts beginning to
reopen some clerk's offices reopen for
filing but there's going to be a huge
backlog isn't there once the courts do
reopen it is going to be a tremendous
backlog particularly
particularly with grand jury indictments
a lot of individuals have been either
languishing in jail waiting to be
indicted and instead they're now
permitting felony examinations and a lot
of people are outside knowing that an
indictment is imminent but grand juries
just haven't convened so prosecutors are
gonna be extremely busy defense
attorneys are gonna be extremely busy
there's going to be a huge backlog and
as a result of that we may expect to see
a higher instance of plea negotiations
and hopefully more favorable offers for
people that are actually deserving and
what happens to the speedy trial rule
well
the speedy trial rule is suspended by
law even though you have a
constitutional right to a speedy trial
but by state law it tends to be
suspended when there is an extraordinary
or an emergency situation obviously
courts have been granting the
applications to prosecutors that 30-30
be suspended as a result of the pandemic
but the problem with that is if this is
indefinite and you don't find a vaccine
for another year and a half or let's
just say six months to eight months you
have individuals that are incarcerated
they're not able to visit with family
members are not able to use the phones
as much they're not able to get rec time
it is torture it is no longer pretrial
confinement it can be cruel and
excessive but at the same time you can't
force 12 to 16 citizens to sit in a
small box together for weeks truly an
issue well I eat a licen ring thank you
so much thank you partners Bruce
Arquette appreciate both of you coming
on today very much very helpful to talk
to you thank you for having us take care
yeah great coming up the race for a
vaccine and the media winners and losers
what did Matt Lauer do you're watching
the lawn crime trial Network
when the case first broke Shannon and
CeCe and Bella were simply missing like
I have no inclination to where they're
at right now something in your gut was
telling you that he had something to do
with it Chris Watts thought that he
could go to the police department
knowing the fact that he killed his
family breeze through a polygraph test
continuing now with the race for a
vaccine everything seems to hinge and
finding some kind of a way to prevent
kovat 19 from taking over our lives
completely to find more about what's
going to happen how soon it might happen
I talked earlier today with dr. William
Schaffner who's professor of preventive
medicine at Vanderbilt University in
Tennessee dr. Schaffner thank you so
much for joining us today the whole
world is waiting for any news about a
vaccine what's the latest from your
point of view and what's your hope about
this well of course we're all hoping
Brian for vaccine absolutely as soon as
possible but that hope is cautioned
because we all know vaccine development
usually takes a fair amount of time and
is often not a straight line but just
the other day dr. Anthony Fauci was a
little more optimistic and he thought
maybe at least one vaccine would be
licensed by sometime this winter well
that's very encouraging I hope that
that's the case I'm not going to put my
dollar on that horse just yet but if it
comes we'll be ready for it
we certainly would like to get it out
here so we can start distributing it and
you know we would distribute it first I
think to healthcare providers and to
first responders and then in a phased
fashion as more and more vaccine becomes
available it would be distributed more
widely to the
population as you know there are dozens
and dozens of candidates under
development now is there one you think
has the most promise well at the moment
the one that seems to be leading the
pack is a one that's being developed by
a group in Oxford England it is using a
new technology we call it an mRNA
vaccine
there's no quite such vaccine that's
been licensed yet although a lot of
scientific work has gone into it over
the years they're entering into clinical
trials large trials to make sure that
it's safe and also of course effective
and if so how effective how many doses
would require be required it might
actually require two doses huh that
would require us to double the amount of
vaccine that we produce and to reach
everyone twice with a needle and syringe
that would make it even more challenging
but so far so good all right dr. Schnurr
a question for you from Rhonda Schwartz
Oh Rhonda doctor Schaffner last month
you said that the virus was getting out
ahead of us how do we get back out ahead
of it what's what's the current
situation what's your outlook now well
at the moment I think we may be tied
with the virus we're keeping up with it
in most parts of the country
we're remaining stable that is everybody
who gets infected is infecting only one
other person rather than two or three
which means we're sort of in a plateau
we're going to see bursts of
transmission here and there and frankly
I was a little worried over the Memorial
Day weekend I saw an awful lot of people
being awfully cavalier being very close
to each other and not wearing masks if
that happens the virus will then get a
jump on us again but at the moment we're
hanging tight and of course the next big
surge that I anticipate will come in the
late fall and early winter wear along
with influenza I think both of those
viruses are going to increase again and
we'll be dealing with a dual
respiratory winter virus season good
grief
doctor Schaffner you were one of the
first to come on our program here on law
and crime and talk about this issue
hasn't played out the way you thought it
would both yes and no this is highly
communicable virus what I firmly been
surprised that is that we haven't had a
more coordinated nationally directed
response there's been an awful lot of ad
hoc e state by state and city by city
that's been necessitated in the past
when we've had large pandemic threats or
infectious disease threats Zika virus
Ebola the 2009 h1n1 influenza the CDC
the public health leadership has taken
the lead and has guided the states and
the states have fallen into line and
generally all been very coherent in
their response it's been much more
disjointed this year and the CDC this
premier public health institution which
I love has been kind of sidelined and
that's unfortunate I think and do you
think the fact that the CDC was
sidelined by the Trump administration
has that cost lives well I think our
response hasn't been nearly as
coordinated as forthright and is bold as
it could have been
and so obviously many more people have
gotten sick and as a consequence some
people have died yes and you're back in
your office now you're continuing to
work what's next do you think well
what's next is developing new therapies
and we're all waiting for the many
trials of different therapeutic agents
different drugs to mature and get us the
data because we need better treatments
fortunately we're starting to test
certainly in my state and others more
extensively so we're doing a better job
in finding cases and our Health
Department has been augmented with case
finders people who can trace the
texts of cases and that's aiding our
Public Health response so we're hanging
in there I think we're doing a better
job of keeping up with the virus but we
can't let our guard down there are
people who would like to go back to the
old normal we have to go forward to a
new normal wearing masks will become
routine the famous or infamous six-foot
rule will still be in place a lot of
good hand hygiene and people who are
older people who have underlying chronic
illnesses they should hold back
particularly from group activities
religious services concerts athletic
events because those kind of grouped
activities are exactly the place that
the Cova virus likes to be transmitted
it remains a very contagious virus and
it will be with us dr. William Schaffner
thank you so much that's tough medicine
but it's something everyone should hear
thank you Brian
coming up this week's winners and losers
in the media see if you agree with the
editor-in-chief of meaty ight you're
watching the law on crime trial Network
when the case first broke shenana and
cece and bella were simply missing like
i have no inclination to where they're
at right now something in your gut was
telling you that he had something to do
with it
Chris Watts thought that he could go to
the police department knowing the fact
that he killed his family breeze through
a polygraph test and we wrap up our
program this week with one of our
favorites the winners and losers in the
media we're joined by Aidan McLaughlin
who's the editor in chief of media part
of the Dan Abrams media family as is the
law and crime Network and Aidan it was
quite a busy week in the media you had a
lots of interesting choices to make we
did yeah it was it's actually been a
fairly surprising weekend in media
happenings you've got a lot of things
roped in from politics angles to tech
angles to the debut of the new press
secretary who joined a couple weeks ago
so it's a really interesting one I'm
starting to get into it right and you
began with winners who to reporters who
went after the new press secretary let's
look at those clips courage every
governor to allow their churches to
reopen and boy it's interesting to be in
a room that desperately wants to seem to
see these churches and houses of worship
stay close the president's
Donna I spent six years in the White
House briefing room covering Ronald
Reagan I have to say I never and in the
years since - I never saw a White House
press secretary
act like that I think her behavior is
indefensible and grotesque so what do
you make of that Aidan that was quite an
attack on the new press secretary and
her maiden voyage almost yeah sure so I
mean let's first go back and look at
what happened with Caylee mackaninee in
that press briefing basically reporters
were questioning the administration on
whether it's wise to open up places of
worship while the corona bear virus
pandemic is still spreading in the
United States it's still ongoing
we know that closed spaces the virus
spreads most easily so there's a lot of
questions as to whether or not it's wise
to be opening up churches and other
places of worship to allow people to
come in and potentially spread the virus
and create hot spots
now Caylee mcenany was getting
questioned about that at the press
briefing and responded by almost
accusing reporters of being uninterested
in having places of worship reopening
when they were just raising legitimate
questions about whether or not that
would be a dangerous idea or a good idea
now Chris Wallace and Jonah Goldberg
here were both speaking on Fox News
Sunday raised some pretty good
criticisms of Caylee mcenany pointed out
that you know that this idea that
reporters in the White House press corps
are sort of have no interest in seeing
places of worship reopen it's sort of
based on a stereotype that reporters are
all cutter of coastal elites and they
don't understand this sort of religious
America and I think they did a really
good job of criticizing Caylee mcenany
and they weren't alone you know Jake
Tapper also criticized her for those
comments over on CNN but it's always
notable when the president's favorite
Network Fox News there is a harsh ly
critical segment calling out the press
secretary of this administration and I
think they were right to call her out
and until we made them winter that day
right at the same time you give to Fox
News you take away you went after britt
hume let's listen to the clip from
Goodhue I think he
when he looks at that picture of Joe
Biden he thinks Biden looks ridiculous
and he kind of does and he didn't want
to look that way and and in fact the
fact that he retweeted that tweet of
mine which I saw they didn't expect
suggests that he agrees with what I said
this is why he won't wear a mask he
doesn't want to look funny so Brett Hume
defending the president there is sort of
like didn't want to be unmanly I guess
huh yeah that was his defense of a tweet
that he put out over Memorial Day
weekend where he essentially mocked Joe
Biden for wearing a mask on Memorial Day
when he was visiting a cemetery and you
know the president has made a point of
not wanting to wear a mask out in public
because he clearly thinks that the
appearance of it is unbecoming Joe Biden
has taken an opposite opposite posture
and has effectively worn the mask out in
public as a sign that you know a
following good health protocol now
what's so bizarre about this is that you
know the Joe Biden wearing the mask is
following the Trump administration's
guidelines on what to do in public you
know the day before he wore the mask on
Memorial Day the Surgeon General Jerome
Adams who works from the Trump
administration put out a video advising
everyone to wear a mask on Memorial Day
if they went out in public so it's just
sort of odd to see britt hume who is a
senior political analyst at fox news
mocking joe biden for following the
trump administration guidelines on
wearing masks on public and then
President Trump retweeting Brit Hume so
sure you can argue that that it's it's
sort of unbecoming to wear masks I'm not
sure why you would I don't think that
Joe Biden looks particularly bad in a
bask I don't think anyone looks
particularly bad in a mask when
particularly when it's just a move to be
safe during a pandemic that has taken
100,000 American lives Brit Hume seems
to think so
I think it's an odd argument to make I
don't think it's defensive the tweet did
anything to make me think that it was
less of a bad idea and again I think it
really needs to be stressed how bizarre
it is that you have a president that is
mocking Joe Biden for following his
administration's own protocol on safety
during the pandemic so
apparently the new normal we're getting
used to the outrageousness of the
president which continues another winter
though you're going after Fox News here
Fox News a victory you call them a
winner why was that short now that was
today we we made Fox News the winner
because Brian we've spoken about this
before there was a lawsuit that was
launched by an activist group called
wash light and it's a group out of
Washington State and they were suing Fox
News and and their case against Fox News
basically held that the network's
downplaying of the coronavirus was in
violation of consumer finance laws in
the state consumer protection laws in
the state excuse me and they're
basically their argument was that Fox
News should not be allowed to have the
same First Amendment protections that
newspapers like the New York Times have
now they brought that lawsuit to a judge
in Washington and that judge on
Wednesday dismissed the case now that's
a huge win for Fox News because it means
that you know Fox News is not going to
be sued over their coverage but it is
also as a win for the press in general
you know Fox News actually got a lot of
support from entities that typically are
harsh critics of the network and I think
this fundamentally boils down to and the
judge echoed this in dismissing this
case is that you can disagree with Fox
News's coverage of the corona virus
pandemic all you want but their their
coverage of it does not should not be
sort of guided or chaperoned by a judge
in Washington state determining what
opinion is legal and what opinion is
illegal so I think the judge throwing
this out is a good step for the First
Amendment it's good for press
organizations for press outlets
everywhere and it was good for Fox News
right I suppose only Fox News would be
surprised that other reporters and news
organizations came to the defense as you
know Aden we had you on earlier this
week with the deputy general counsel the
top newsroom lawyer for the New York
Times who said of course David Macross
said that Fox News enjoyed the same
protections as the New York Times when
it came to the First Amendment so that
was a victory for Fox News and
the first amendment let me ask you now
the next looser you chose we're going to
talk about Twitter and Jack Dorsey yeah
so it's a really really rough week for
Jack doors who's the CEO of Twitter it
actually keeps getting worse for him
basically the culmination of a and
almost years long pressure campaign on
behalf of critics of the President to
get Jack Dorsey and Twitter to take
action against President Donald Trump's
tweets pretty much culminated at the
beginning of the week when President
Donald Trump has been pushing this
absurd conspiracy theory that Joe
Scarborough who is you know the MSNBC
host of Morning Joe had something to do
with the death of a congressional aide
in his office when he was a congressman
in Florida more than two decades ago
President Donald Trump has been pushing
this conspiracy theory that Joe
Scarborough somehow had something to do
with that and you know coming very close
to accusing Joe Scarborough of murder in
a series of tweets now a lot of people
have been calling on Twitter
particularly become Brzezinski who is
the wife now of Joe Scarborough I've
been calling on Twitter to take action
and to delete those tweets from
President Donald Trump now the widower
of the the young woman who died in Joe
scarborough's office is also calling on
Twitter to delete those tweets now
Twitter resisted those calls they did
not take any action against those tweets
from the president but they did later
that day when they were getting immense
pressure this week to take action
against the president's tweet they added
a note to one of his tweets about
mail-in ballots it linked to a fact
check that basically said that the
president's comments about mail and
voting were inaccurate and that drew
harsh criticism from the president I
don't think it's satisfied many of
Twitter's critics that they were
effectively taking taking this seriously
enough and now the president has said
that today he's going to unveil an
executive order targeting social media
platforms for bias against conservatives
which is you know it should alarm
conservatives everywhere that the
president is talking about regulating
social media platforms because you know
on First Amendment grounds but now you
know Jack Dorsey I don't think
satisfied critics we really think the
president Donald Trump should be booted
from Twitter altogether
he certainly has drawn the furious ire
of the president who is now calling for
Twitter to be regulated and the
president even called in a tweet earlier
this week to shut down Twitter so he's
sort of in an impossible position now he
can't boot president Donald Trump off
the platform because the president is
the president has a huge following and
that would create a gigantic problems
for Twitter no matter what you think of
the president's tweets so Jack Dorsey is
in an impossible position now and now
he's attracted furious criticism for the
president who's looking to wield
executive power to punish Twitter for
these move you can see why he's a loser
he really couldn't win whatever he did
and it's a long time coming this issue
of are they publishers are just sort of
a bulletin board for others to put up
their words sure yeah and that's always
been the problem with Twitter it's do
they say that they're a publisher and
then they're allowed to make editorial
decisions about what kind of content get
published on their platform or do they
take the fact that now Mark Zuckerberg
is saying Facebook takes where they are
simply refusing to determine what is
true and what is false and saying that
we are just an open forum for people to
post now there's all sorts of problems
with that when it comes to hate speech
you know every social media platform
needs guidelines that users have to
adhere to when you get into issues with
facts that becomes a real problem for
social media platforms because you know
is Twitter going to basically farm out
their fact-checking to CNN The
Washington Post to other reporters which
is what they did with this mail-in
ballot tweet it linked to a fact check
from CNN um you know do they do it
in-house which is going to take a you
know a remarkable amount of resources to
fact-check every single tweet that gets
published on on Twitter that gets that
gets flagged as having potential
misinformation it creates the debate in
and of itself about which one of the
president's tweets are inaccurate and
and you know fact-checking is just a
really sort of a difficult part of
journalists job for social media
platforms to be taking on that
responsibility is a really tough feat so
you know again it's a really problematic
position for Jack Dorsey to be in I
don't envy him
right and now it's being attacked by
Mark Zuckerberg and Facebook he can't
win it's a tough one I recall that you
know lots of companies talked about
buying Twitter they didn't want to touch
it it's like a third rail aidan thank
you so much lot more to come this week
right yeah yeah yeah we've got you know
there we're waiting to see what happens
with this executive order
I know Kaylee McEnaney just wrapped up a
press briefing I'm sure that there's a
lot of news coming out of that so yeah
well check-in back in for winterizer
tomorrow I'm sure there'll be a lot more
all right Thank You Aidan thanks to all
of you for joining us and thanks to
those at the longtime team that get us
on the air and off the air
[Music]